what is happening there reject nation
john and greg have returned for another
marvel show and we got this guy to do a
one-off with us for this whole series
koi zhandro our comic book expert follow
him he is committing to the midnight
shows with us thank you so much coy
you're a big hawkeye fan right huge
hawkeye fan i dressed as hawkeye for the
first avengers film oh nice back when i
was a fan i came to the premiere as
hawkeye was it because it was
cost-effective because it's cheaper than
being iron man
please go ahead and uh hit that target
of a like button
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction for hawkeye is uh full-length
watch long as we sync up with the show
or over at our patreon page over there
cover a bunch of shows with the same
tier you get the option for both
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included lastly thank you to the boys
over at prepper for editing now these
highlights i'm very much excited for
this i'm like three issues away from
finishing that matt fraction run koi's
read it and is like one issue away from
the re-reading it yep john's a few
issues in right now we gotta let all
that go and just accept whatever it is
they're doing here it's not just gonna
be a big comparison one but we did some
of our homework anywho let's see what's
in store
[Music]
twice adventures
[Music]
little cape
got it under control
do you wanna
who are we kidding you go
kate and her having a strange
relationship
there for micah always fighting with her
kids no right
except in conjure
i don't want to move
that much huh we don't have to how do
you know
mommy said things don't just fall from
the sky
it's 2012
about to fall from the sky the chitauri
come in through the window
what's happening oh it is
[Music]
i already got nipple chills
[Music]
wow oh boy
[Applause]
the shot
oh cool
oh i love that you're getting this
perspective that's awesome
this looks bad
i need to protect us
okay that's my job okay
whatever you need i'm here for you
i need a bow and arrow
[Laughter]
oh man it's just david a hot heart yeah
wow
i didn't realize just exactly how sore
it was gonna be damn
yes that's right tony dalton's in this
show
[Music]
i love the whimsical music like
there's this underscore but also the the
tim burton whimsy of christmas
[Music]
it's crazy you got all her core memory
wounds all in one scene i thought it was
great to like actually
sometimes i feel like when we revisit
the 2012 events it's like just shots
from the movie yeah these are all new
shots today
sometimes you gotta dress the part
i know it's a bed but are you sure that
arrow won't damage it no
[Music]
hang on
let me just fix this give me a second
dude haley steinfeld is so perfectly
cast for this role insane how perfect
she is
i bet that's gonna be recurring like in
the comic that's great
back muscle's tense
exhale yeah
that's uh that's not great
but it could be worse
yes
i know i'd go
[Music]
do it do it do it
[Music]
like she sounds just like how i'd
imagine kate to say it's incredible
accuracy
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
i'll be there
oh
oh
oh yeah
he can't hear
oh he's here he lost his hearing yeah
did you turn your hearing aid off
no honey
i know what happens
[Music]
[Music]
dude it sounds like exactly what they
would make yeah this is the spider-man
musical in new york city
let's try to turn off the dark gonna
play in this but they did it good for
all they got to release that they got
released
like the zemo clip the whole thing
there you are
wow wow you look
amazing
melisandre
security auction
you know right all those poor people and
non-profits relying on the more
fortunate that is not what i meant
we're going to have a much longer talk
about this tower that you destroyed
without joking i know that young people
think they're invincible and rich people
think they're invincible and you have
always been both so
[Laughter]
you will get hurt
so please don't go out looking for it
yeah it's simba
what's with all the swords mom
there's been a few changes while you're
away this semester
jack
oh is it gonna be the swordsman yeah
that's great yeah
how was the show
it was it was uh
it's over it was big
there you go there you have it
[Laughter]
hold your brother's hands
i love you guys
love you too it's gonna be the best
spartan christmas ever
all right ain't nothing bad gonna happen
today no foreshadowing here yeah
it's necessary you saved our city
oh
thank you
hmm except the perks man you're not a
superhuman
you just have to sit through that play
bro yeah
you got a family to feed excuse me dear
would you sorry i'm not a waitress
you're the little bishop girl
i thought he called her a [ __ ]
a little [ __ ] girl
i'd appreciate it if you wear something
a little more ladylike for the wedding
so we won't be competing
what wedding
you don't know
eleanor and jack
those
secrets
[Music]
then come back and find me okay yeah
maybe tell everyone at your party you
know like
you know navigate daughter doesn't know
yet so why don't you just keep a secret
[Laughter]
already pizza dog ah
she gets him
oh
his life's already messed up
that's probably we're not gonna see the
origin of how he got his eye messed up
on his disney [ __ ] could be a flashback
he better get his own episode
i think they'd have that conversation
with the door closed
mom what was that about is that guy
threatening you i honestly i i have no
idea
right there all right
she is such a good mission for turning
around like every moment of like how did
they pluck her out of yeah she's perfect
yeah thanking their lucky star she said
yes
this good thing she looks just like the
waiters convenient joke paid off
[Music]
the auction
this seat is
taken but sit on my lap
start the bidding for this magnificent
skull at two million dollars do i hear
two million dollars two million better
looking at 2.1 i've got 2 million do i
hear 2.1 this is the slowest talking
auctioneer i've ever heard you should
have called me oh great
working here uh gary
gary sent me to
work here
uh so many of you if you want to bother
gary
you're doing great
[Laughter]
i told you to come down here
gary
i'm gary
[Laughter]
this is not gonna work out i quit you
can't quit hold on
grab a bottle while you're in there it's
got to be all at least like 50 to 100
years old
evil why
oh yeah bro yeah bro
an artifact recovered from the wreckage
of the avengers compound
[Music]
ronin blade
they called him ronin yeah 250 thank you
sir do i hear 300
300 looking for 350. what are you doing
you dope
i'm buying that sword the thing for
swords sold for 475 000 up next we have
lot number 309 the companion piece the
ronin suit
oh
yeah get that cake oh
i have no idea who that is
the villain yeah i can't tell yet
or do you have a idea
maybe there you go
swordsman mm-hmm
yeah
i don't know why did you go there yeah i
was like i just showed them
well you know you should add a higher up
figure so
we've got 90 seconds to find a watch
everything else is second there let's go
put on the suit
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh ouch yeah
[Music]
damn
strong glass
oh
yes
[Music]
love how much struggles with her voice
the whole time yeah
she's such a tiny
[Music]
nice nice
rewards i found it
hey
oh boy
oh boy
jack's gotta know that it was her in the
costume right got to yeah
check it out
a ninja saved a dog
[Laughter]
in new york
he was rodent
avengers movie flashbacks
later period flashbacks
food you want food uh of course oh
uh
okay
hang on i'm gonna get you some food
the pizza dog
origin story
here is the most original story
i like pizza
whole box for that one pizza
monogrammed butterscotch
[Laughter]
rich people man
[Music]
mr ducane have your dry cleaning and i
brought dinner get out of that
good old christmas murder mystery
huh the van bro
no
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
come on hot wear that
oh my boys
[Music]
come on
[Laughter]
and who the hell are you
[Music]
episode great place to end episode one
yes
well done
consulting producer perfection
nice that explains a lot all right first
episode down they already released a
second episode so obviously the
intention is for us to watch both back
to back so we're gonna keep this very
brief let's start with sir john i mean
i've had a blast with this i loved the
introduction just to you know where
we're meeting kate where we're meeting
clint after you know a certain amount of
time i enjoyed the cutting back and
forth between them and sort of building
up just yeah where we're meeting them
until they finally collide at the end i
really love just getting to know hailey
steinfeld's version of kate bishop i
agree with every sentiment you guys have
thrown out that yeah i mean she seems
like the perfect choice for this great
supporting cast thus far i can't wait to
watch the second one coy i mean this is
a ryan reynolds robert turner junior
chris evans level casting choice these
this is plucked from the comic book
haley steinfeld is kate bishop i enjoy
the preposterousness of wealth they're
kind of playing with here because that
really ties into the dichotomy between
her and clint i've liked that they've
made some choices about certain
instances that happened to clint have
happened to kate a lot of the things
that we've seen so far were a hawkeye
story they're now using this way because
hawkeye in the comic books in a
different place in his life than hawkeye
in the movie so i think that's been a
clever use of the youth of kate bishop
and i've really enjoyed the fact that
it's felt like this is like a 70 30
split with kate and clint and they're
both hawkeye and that's so important to
me with the comic books so the fact that
the show is giving us a very
introductory origin of cape bishop it
doesn't feel like it's shying away from
the fact that we have two hawkeyes
coming out of the show i'm really liking
the 70 30 split so far 70 30 i mean like
70 percent bigger
30
i was actually surprised by that i was
surprised by how it was so cape focus
and clint was barely in this episode he
was like barely in it yeah it might be
80 20.
once you get it there
did you guys see the cameo did i just
want to think he's in it yeah i think
that's really smart of them and i'm
enjoying that tone for me
yeah man i like the opening a lot i'm
waiting for the second episode i am
because there's some parts of it that
felt a tad off to me i'm not sure what
it is yet it's not my favorite first
episode of marvel tv here what i'm about
to say is a thing i like a lot about it
but then with that there's also some
things within it that i i'm not the
biggest fan of just yet so i'm kind of
waiting to see how the groove goes with
it i love the choice to make this feel
so much like a christmas show it's not
just a christmas background like the way
how you know people compare it to die
hard which is like christmas is
happening in the background and shane
black often christmas is happening in
the background [ __ ] it's in the
foreground sir it's in the foreground
organizations it's in the music choices
it's in the characters
it's in the objective this feels like a
christmas movie yeah you know what i
mean
it feels way more it doesn't have as
much of the grit of a shame black thing
obviously you wouldn't get that on
disney this feels like a disney
christmas movie in a lot of ways yeah
which was i was a little bit surprised
by it from beginning to end almost every
scene has a holiday vibe to it not just
in its aesthetic but just in the way
it's being shot the music that they're
using throughout sometimes it makes it
feel like a little more cheesy than i
actually expected it to feel with
certain parts of like kate's
interactions with other people like i
think verify mega is is awesome in here
and i think they're totally going to
change her to be a villain which
i think she's mad at masks
of course that all right
[Laughter]
i
very
much
to dump too into it in case because it's
like it could be a big spoiler if that's
true i don't know what you're talking
about right who's that oscar we already
said it
comic book credibility is way more
important than anyone's enjoyment into
the show
we gotta prove that we're smart this
episode in particular was like oh man i
i really because i heard a couple people
say that they think she might turn into
madam mask i was watching this i'm like
oh she's probably totally mad about
in every encounter we see her in and
swordsman i didn't expect in the in the
opening i mean they didn't even really
do much other than to elude that hey
what's his sword doing here him enter
frame that's the swordsman that man has
a mustache that's a swordsman mustache
but i'm wondering if they're gonna
retcon his origin story because it's so
tied in to clint to clint yeah cause the
thing is it's really easy to look at
stuff and go oh that's neat how they're
pulling from the comic oh that's saying
how they're changing is not exactly how
hawkeye or clint i should say clint and
kate met in the comics it's not 100
there's some things about it that are
fairly similar enough you know i'm
really sure there's like a buddy yes
because she stole his costume and [ __ ]
that's very yeah yeah it's a different
costume but you got to take it on some
merits and what they're presenting
itself too and and i think like with the
the way they established the tone like
this really does feel like it's a show
about family and it does take place
during christmas i felt surprisingly
you know what it is it felt lighter than
i expected it to but i don't know if
that's a bad thing you know i see that i
personally thought it would be
a little more
of the
hawkeye tone like i thought it'd be a
little lighter actually i thought it'd
be like you know the scene and age of
ultron where he's making quips and jokes
all the time and yeah he's the so it's
actually a little darker than i expected
but it's also very christmassy so it's
an interesting tone so far i'm waiting
for the action to dazzle me because i
thought the action in this episode was
serviceable but in a show that is
centered around two people who just have
really really honed skills and abilities
i feel like that could pack a little
more of like all the fights are fine
chorography is fine i'm still waiting in
this show for a moment where i'm like
yeah yeah some real hawkeye action we're
gonna watch the second episode and a big
charm to what this show has to be is the
chemistry between the body count yeah
the buddy cop dynamic so i've been
itching for that you know he does that
well shane black with his christmas
movies i agree
all right when we saw the trailer the
first thing i said was like this is like
a shane black movie but it felt more
like do you get it fed my boy did you
get it all where i'm coming from here
this episode didn't really feel like
shane black to me this felt more like a
christmas movie to me it feels like a
disney channel original movie yes yeah
and i'm not an insult but in a way that
feels like a disney channel christmas
thing i got you i don't know i'm waiting
for something a little bit more with a
bit more of an oomph to it i don't
really even know what i anticipated for
this show i just expected like a good
marvel show that's about it
yeah you know we're getting about what i
would have anticipated at the start you
know i think that's a really solid
foundation man right now i think it's
good i wouldn't say great although you
if the second episode really clicks
that's why they're i think there's a
reason they're at least two there's a
reason there's a yeah usually when they
do that i'm like it feels kind of weird
to sit here and talk because i'm like i
would kind of treat the first and second
episode like one episode yeah i feel
like i could take it back to our house
is there a point of us really sitting
here and discussing the first episode
because yeah you should judge a whole
series based on the pilot
oh we're done right now watch it not
watch the progression of how it all went
down but i do think haley steinfeld is
perfectly cast like even when she has
the mask on when she's like talking with
lucky the pizza dog sounds like thought
bubbles are going off yeah carries the
monologuing so well like the thinking
out loud so well and her little quips
and her little digs are so okay bishop
because kate bishop's always got those
little like glass boops yes and i like
that uh this version that we've gotten
teased of clint like was around his
family he looks really happy but you can
see on his little isolated looks he does
seem really sad internally and a bit of
an apathetic nature to his presence and
i like seeing that version of clinton i
feel like jeremy wright is going to give
some really good stuff because whenever
he comes to jeremy renner i was like
yeah jeremy and i think i do think i
kind of wish we got a little bit more of
him in the first episode i did find
myself kind of wanting occasionally to
cut back to him i felt like we needed to
get bishop origin so it didn't distract
me but i see where you're coming from
yeah i think i think i think we need a
cape bishop origin too john how are you
feeling you're in the middle of your are
you all coincidental or something here i
was pretty fine with the proportions
that they did here i mean i get where
you're coming from because there is a
certain element of clint is mostly only
doing family stuff and and then at the
end he jumps in and there's like not a
ton of a transition to that so i could
have maybe used maybe one more scene or
something between them getting back to
their hotel and him coming out to find
her but see i'm wondering if the second
episode's going to be like really
clint's perspective because
that's really great yeah yeah like the
comic does a really good job making it
so the other is the supporting character
and that's why i love that they're like
hawkeye hawkeye like there's this great
like we are hawkeye that it feels like
the comic understands that in a way that
it's like a 70 30 80 20 split with each
issue and they give it so i'm curious if
the show does that and if we get a pizza
dog episode i hope so man i hope so but
did we really get a kate origin because
i'm like how is she
who she is
because she's a black belt of 15. yeah
that's all i got for you being snarky
and rich
yeah yeah we saw we saw we got the
exposition version we got to hear about
it but what i really did and the
graphics i'm not saying it's a complaint
i'm saying that i think there's still
more to unpack there i do really like
like the origin of her in the very
opening scene like how it was a wonder
shot exploring all that seeing like the
day her dad died it was also the day she
saw hawkeye as the savior yeah you know
so wanting to embody that role i thought
was great everything they do with like
kate specifically and i think vera
farmiga is also really wonderful here
like she weaves in and out of this
personality so seamlessly in between
scenes like she seems like a real mom to
her
and then she seems like oh she you know
i like the the sneaking suspicions that
you have about her she gets stern at the
appropriate moments like she has a lot
of qualities going on that i think very
far that like only actress like vera
farmiga's caliber could actually pull
off because she's one of the best
actresses working today so i really like
her a lot and i like it's like that's
what i mean like i don't really like
about it i was like i can't quite
pinpoint what it is that was a little
off for me
but we'll see maybe it doesn't even
matter let's watch the second episode
it's like that's what i'm saying what
the hell are we doing here yeah
let's just watch the second episode in
real life if there was not a camera
point on us we would just watch the
first two back-to-back
everything we were saying in the episode
one like the first ten minutes i was
like yeah this is already making all of
episode one a lot better it's just weird
being the one guy who's like i was like
i gave it like a like it's not the best
it's a solid start but it's yeah guys
make me feel better
my emotions and my perspective you feel
better guys i really enjoyed this it's
not the strongest pilot but it's a good
jumping off point let's build on this i
think so far it's between
like it's not loki which was like
transcendent tv and it's not as low as
what if but it's like in that mid-range
it didn't do anything um
special for me that's probably what it
is it's like there was nothing special
about this episode to me everything that
you haven't seen before in the mcu in
any way but what i like about the way
how kate fights though even though the
fights weren't all that impressive from
the start she has to get better everyone
has to get better
but what i liked was the sounds of her
struggling
was like oh it's kind of like watching a
video game yeah yeah yeah and i really
bought it as her like yes some people
but i felt like oh that's haley
steinfeld and she probably did a fair
amount of her own stuff because she's a
boss she wasn't just someone who was
like just handling business like a total
lethal warrior wasn't like right
like you really felt like the i i like
when there's like a performance to the
fighting of like she's you really feel
like she's improvising all this that
she's
of her which going
mentioned at one point like she seems
like a small 90 pound person fighting
these bros well yeah and even in the
costume it's like it's like appreciate
that it's not quite well fitting on her
like it's a little ill-fitting because
it's not her build it's not her costume
so you know like i think i think that in
some ways could contribute to it looking
a little funky but also i think it also
adds authenticity yeah true true true i
also like that most of the things we've
seen in the trailer we've seen the first
episode so now we're getting into new
stuff yeah they really brought the track
suit tracks it mafia to like with the
clip they say bro all right guys keep a
lookout for our next reaction probably
upload it like a little bit after this
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
jason dolan he's a man who's easily the
best one to shout out for this because
in a lot of ways he is clint barton and
he has his own kate bishop named kazzy
reacts cazzy reacts as an awesome
youtube channel those wonderful
reactions hilarious sincere
genuine you think that with all the
skills and personality that jason dolan
has that he would be the star of his own
show but no he's going to make cazzy
take over the mantle which he's already
done so so successfully so guys if i'm
shouting out jason that means i'm really
shouting out cazzy reacts go check out
her channel on a sincere notice it is
really they're really great videos and
they are really funny and uh sometimes i
cry because she's crying yeah if you're
looking for some genuine reactions go
check her out as far as jason goes he's
kind of an [ __ ] but he's the kind of
[ __ ] you love you know what i mean
the kind of [ __ ] you're like
you know i could tell there's a heart
underneath all that tough exterior
someone more can you ask for from a guy
jason i like you buddy cazzy i love you
girl
greg
i like editing these down